people all over the world are listening
to this and arguing about it
do you hear Yanni or Laurel yeah yeah
yeah how does anybody hear Laurel out of
that we're gonna do this ahead why the
answer is so important to so many of us
you are watching CBS like Laurel you
hear Laurel yeah no no no
welcome back to CBS this morning where
they yeah Neil oral debate continues
that we're gonna take it into the green
room Marc Benioff top CEO dr. Samson
Davis and Charlie Jeter coming to the
table Nets with guys do you hear yeah
knee or do you hear Laurel mark meeting
off you go first
I heard you Annie what does it mean okay
Charlie what are you here charlie Jeter
Laurel yeah me yeah
Samson Davis what are you here obviously
yeah knee okay they say people over the
people of 25 tend to hear ya knee you're
younger you hear ya knee if you're older
you tend to hear Laurel it's all has to
do with higher you're higher so there
you go mark video proof you guys are so
you have young ears I like it I like it
I like it I like it